[Musique]
les amis mais où le tulle où tu le tour
de bouger ainsi tu vas faire basculer
notre nuage qu'est ce que tu cherches
mon panier à provisions il est devant
toi gros nigo hop suisse butt patron je
descends chez pimprenelle et nicolas et
si vous le permettez j'ai une petite
course à faire après biensir 2 nov merci
je dois m'acheter du dentifrice à la
chlorophylle
et tu as besoin de ce grand panier pour
un petit tube de dentifrice
oui mais il m'en faut que le culot moi
quand je regarde je me lave bien
[Musique]
beau poupon
a marché j'ai dû me trompe lui
[Applaudissements]
j'étais prom a vendre des rouges des
blanches battre pour un sou mademoiselle
retourner
chez moi clients faut toujours commencer
par les legs aux épaules et
je préférerais monsieur marchand du
dentifrice halak lors office âgées passe
à monsieur dommage alors un kilo de
pommes de terre
[Musique]
c'est ça un kilo de pommes de terre
qu'elle marche on voit la france
vous voulez aussi des carats je
préfèrerais du dentifrice aulas mais je
vous ai dit que j'ai pas de ficelle
dentifrice d'europe cela tenait voilà
qu'une autre car at il y en a pas lourd
dans ce kilo vous prenez aussi des
poireaux à kiel bon à boire aux
homes et des dons ya vraiment un kilo
merci
mais c'est bien dommage que vous n'ayez
pas de dentifrice je vous ai dit que
j'allais pas aller voir plutôt la petite
dame qui vend des fruits et l'a
impressionné acheter
bonjour madame la marchande
du dentifrice à la chlorophylle
papa taguer free libya
arab alors quelques oranges
[Musique]
volontiers
ses choix
non non voilà six francs et merci
dommage que vous n'ayez pas de
dentifrice 'le
du dentifrice
qu'est ce qu'il me faut j'en veux du bon
à la chlorophylle celui-ci mesure
combien vous l'avons beaucoup je veux me
faire de belles tente alors voilà toute
ma prévision ça fait enfant ce cher mais
je perds je suis ravi ce que je vais
être beau home et beldan elles vont
briller elles vont brieuc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors tu as fait des achats oui patron
et voilà du temps tifrit salah fort
officielle du vrai regardez
mais
ne nous c'est du cirage noir
pardon je malentendu c'est du cirage
noir au lait petits jobs
ils m'ont vendu du cirage le corps ne
ment ou alors ne t'énerve pas qui leur
fera une blague toi aussi oh oui soyez
tranquilles en route bonne nuit les
enfants très peu pour
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]